[音楽]
ロンこんにちはえ
今日の話は
田舎という言葉を考える
ています
a まずは
このころから
言葉に興味を持ち
外国語
学ぶのがとにかく大好きでした
まあ今も大好きですが
そして日本語を学び始めたのが1996年で
20年以上
と最近は得に
まあ日本語の勉強の中でですね
言葉が持つ意味をじっくり考えるようになりまし
今日はその中で私にとって一番興味のある言葉の話を
それは
中
そこで皆さんにここにいる皆さんに
まず質問したいと思います
皆さんはこの田舎という言葉をどのように考えますか
私は大学生時代に日本語を専攻して日本語を学びながら
一つのことが頭に浮かんできました
それはもう
留学するしかないと
まあその留学先をここしまい大学に
さあ決めたんですがその理由はいろいろありますがその一つに日本から
私の大学にたくさんの留学生も
いまして
その留学生の言葉で
マネって
とっても田舎だよ
ということがよく聴いてたんですよ
でまぁそれを聞いて
ね
なんかあんまり良い意味合いで使ってないなぁと
まあ口調ですぐわかりました
まあそれでも
私そこで思ったのは
本当にそれ遊歩道の田舎なのか
日本の田舎でどんな田舎なんだと
まあいうことを思っています
えーまぁなぜなら私は皆アメリカのあの田舎生まれで
田舎育ちです
アメリカの田舎はよくしている
けれども日本の甍は
違い
なので見てみたいなと行く気持ちがまあ旦那大きくなっていきました
しかしそれとともにあまりにも彼らが
ことにしちゃう
とに当てだよとっても嫌だよと
繰り返して繰り返し言うので
ちょっと不安になってきました
一体日本の田舎ってどんなものなのか
どんなところなのか
まあそういう不安があったんですね
なぜかというとそれが道の田舎ですから
まぁいらがそのものに対しての不安ではないんですね
田舎という言葉の壁に
行く手を遮られたような気がしました
まあ日本語も日本そのものも学びたい私でしたが
日本に行って
果たしてうまくやっていけるのだろうかと
ええまあその不安が
だんだん膨らんでしまいました
まああのもちろん
も否かという基準が私の
生まれた公共育った環境です
まあだから家です
まあ日本語を理解したわけでもなくまあ日本という田舎
まあ日本という未知の田舎で一人でやっていけるかどうかというのがやっぱり心配は
出発日が近づくにつれて増していく一方でした
そしてやってきました来日の良いです
空港に降り立って迎えに来てくれたえ
友達にこれから1年間過ごす島根県松井氏の
まあに向かって
連れて行ってもらいました
夜だったので
空港を離れると
明かりが p
ポツも本当にまるでやのこの会場のように
この灯りがぽつんぽつんと
なるくらいでしたねー
それを見るとやはり私は[ __ ]っ
お願いところに来ちゃったのかなと
まあ思いましたがええまああの進むと徐々に灯りが戻ってきて
建物や車も増えてきて
これは私が想像したほどの田舎じゃないなぁと
まあ思いました
それから過ごす1年間
一つ大きな疑問が
を開いてきました
自分の基準でむしろこの辺が
を都会だと
都会のようなところだとへ
いう松江 c ではいろんな方に
アウトーよくあのここは田舎で姉という
言葉を
弾きました
どう考えてもその田舎って言う
まあ考え方に対しての
見合いで使ってないなとやっぱり思ってました
この田舎の家は
まあそのそれがそれこそだ私の持ってた疑問です
留学が終わり大学卒業後に再びに
まあ島に戻ってきたきてからも
をそのことをずーっと言われ続いています
中でねー
いうことですねえまあその
まあそのそんなに田舎であることは悪いことなのか
というのは和をもってこの田舎という言葉にはどんな意味合いが入っている
田舎っていう言葉が持っている意味は何なのかというのがええ
この疑問が深まる一方でした
そこで自分なりに
田舎という言葉はちょっと定義その定義に挑戦してみました
まあ田舎とはなんぞや
ねええ田舎という言葉に不能印象はあるんか
なぜなぜそれがあるのか
どうしてその負の印象にしてしまうのだろうかと
先ず一つ命にこの
田舎=東京じゃないというマイナスイメージ
むしろ
東京じゃなければ田舎だと言う
なんかニュアンスがちょっと入っているかなと
私はあの思います
は事実いろいろな分野においては東京が日本の中心になっていて
まあ比較されるも
無理はないこと団はわかっています
ただ
まあ東京じゃないからといってそれを悪いことじゃない
ねっ東京は東京
他のところは第二の東京になる必要は一切ありません
いいじゃねーな
いうのは私は思います
また
あのもう一つは伊那回ゴルフ弁当
いうマイナスな意味合いも入っていると思います
確かに都会とよく言われるようなところに比べていろいろなことにおいては不便かも
しれません
さあそれに対して疑問があります
その不便と言っているところは
本当にそんなにマイナスだとことばかりなのだろうか
まあ交通の便が悪いのかアクセスがしにくいと
確かに田舎の交通には
バスや電車の本数は少ないのは
あります
しかしアクセスしにくいからずこそそこにいく過程で
いろんなことだ
に誰に聞いたり知ったりすることができるそういう楽しさもあるので
をはないかと私は思います
もえっすいませんもう一つ
田舎=人間関係が難しい
いうところは強いイメージも入っているんじゃないかと思います
まあこれも
一理はありますが近所付き合いがほぼ皆無という東京の一面はありません
東京とか都会ですねすいません
都会のそのごちゃごちゃしている中で
6資料を
ちょっとここどこスアのある種類の孤独さを感じます
それに比べると伊那たには特別の田舎といわれるところには特別の暖かさ
そしてまぁなによりも田舎からイゴル
マニーもうない
というマイナスのイメージも
強いと
何もないということですが
ありえないんですね
あの何もないというのは本当にヤれないんですよ
何を求めているかによってはまあそう思えるかもしれませんが何もないことは絶対ない
です
買い物や娯楽
はまあ1件
東海といわれるところはまあ圧倒的に多いのは確かですが
しかし都会になく田舎にあるものもたくさんあります
まあ
例えばね
そうですね綺麗な
ネオン街のところでこう夜になると
夜空見上げても星はほとんど見えません
皆からだからこそもう本当にこう空に散りばめられた星がたくさんあるのが
感動をそのままです
自然の偉大な存在を感じることができます
また青おいしい空気というの終わり
まああの空気にアジアがあると
まあ思える思うかもしれませんが私の経験上
と会に行くと
空気にちょっと焦げた味
ぱいあ
化学物質ぽい味がするんですよ
まあそれに比べて自然の多い中では
空気に住ん
澄んだ味わいが
生活の余裕もあります
伊那あの都会の日常的なあの流れの速さは本当にすま g
もう本あの壮麗についていく人には別の意味で損壊
尊敬します
私には無理ですもっとゆっくり生きていきたいタイプなんですね
でまぁ田舎だからこそ時間に余裕をもって
生活でができると思います
まあそして見る目を持てば
まあ必ず何か
面白い何かを見つけることができるんですよ
何もないではなく何かあるというのは田舎の
特徴です
まあそういう発想何かあると言う
の発想の転嫁をすれば
まあ見えてくるも本当にたくさんあるんですね
小さな滝だったりとか
お寺とか
花
とか美味しい店とかいろいろなものをもう本当に探せばあるんです
都会でない田舎だからといって悪いわけじゃない
田舎には田舎の良さは山ほどあります
この話を聞いデー
少し前方何かを思ってもらえたら幸いです
まあ田舎の定義にはまだ結論が出ないでー
継続中ですが
a それでは最後にもう一度
みなさんに質問します
この田舎という言葉を
どのように考えますか
定義するなろう
否かをどのように定義しますか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]